The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --equal
forces of light.
But before we get
started with it,
do you have any question
about the last lecture, which
was on open quantum system--
Quantum Monte Carlo methods--
and in particular, the
conceptual things we discussed
is what happens when
you do a measurement,
or when you don't
detect a photon,
how does it change
the wave function?
And this was
actually at the heart
of realizing similar
quantum systems,
and simulating them using
quantum Monte Carlo methods.
Any question?
Any points for discussion?
OK.
Today is, actually
conceptually, a simple lecture,
because I'm not
really introducing
some subtleties of
quantum physics.
We know our Hamiltonian--
the dipole Hamiltonian--
this is the fully
quantized Hamiltonian,
how atoms interact with
the electromagnetic field.
And, of course,
it's fully quantized
because E perpendicular
is the operator
of the quantized
electromagnetic field,
and it's the sum of
a plus a [? dega. ?]
But when it comes to forces,
it's actually fairly simple.
We don't introduce
anything else.
This is our Hamiltonian.
This is the energy.
And the force is nothing
else than the gradient
of this energy.
So I decided it today--
it's rather unusual--
but I will have everything
pre-written, because I think
the concentration of new
ideas is not so high today,
so I want to go a
little bit faster.
But I invite everybody
if you slow me down
if you think I'm going
too fast and if you
think I'm skipping something.
Also another
justification is at least
the first 30%, 40%
of this lecture,
you've already done as a
homework assignment, when
you looked at the classical
limit of mechanical forces.
You actually had
already, as a preparation
for this class, a
homework assignment
on the spontaneous scattering
force and the stimulated dipole
force.
PROFESSOR: Well, the
only subtlety today
is how do we deal
with a fully quantized
electromagnetic field?
But what I want to show you
in the next few minutes is
in the end, we actually
do approximations
that the quantized
electromagnetic field pretty
much disappears
from the equation.
We have a classical field.
And then, almost everything
you have done in your homework
directly applies.
The only other thing we do
today is the dipole moment.
Well, we use, for the
dipole moment of the atom,
the solution of the
Optical Bloch Equation.
So I think now you
know already everything
we do in the first
30, 40 minutes.
PROFESSOR: So we get rid of
all of the quantum character
of the electromagnetic
field in two stages.
One is the following,
well, we want
to describe the interactions
of atoms with laser fields.
And that means the
electromagnetic field
is in a coherent state.
And you know from
several weeks ago,
the coherent state
is a superposition
of a [INAUDIBLE] states,
coherent superposition
and such, so they're
really photons inside.
It's a fully quantized
description of the laser beam.
But now-- and this is something
if you're not familiar,
you should really
look up-- there
is an exact canonical
transformation
where you transform
your Hamiltonian--
you do, so to speak, a
basis transformation--
to another Hamiltonian.
And the result is, after
this unitary transformation,
the coherent state is
transformed to the vacuum
state.
So in other words, the
quantized electromagnetic field
is no longer in
the coherent state,
it's in the vacuum state.
But what appears
instead is a purely
classical electromagnetic field.
A c number.
So you can sort of say--
I'm waving my hands now--
the coherent state
is the vacuum,
with a displacement operator.
All the quantumness of
the electromagnetic field
is in the vacuum
state, and that's
something we have
to keep because this
is responsible for
spontaneous emission quantum
fluctuations and such.
But the displacement
operator, which
gives us an arbitrary
coherent state, that
can be absorbed by
completely treating
the electromagnetic
field classically.
So therefore, we take the fully
quantized electromagnetic field
and we replace it now by a
classical field, and simply
the vacuum fluctuation.
So there are no
photons around anymore.
There is the vacuum ready
to absorb the photons,
and then there's a classical
electromagnetic field,
which drives the atoms.
And, of course, the classical
electromagnetic field
is not changing because
of absorption emission,
because it's a c number
in our Hamiltonian.
So this is an important
conceptual step,
and it's the first
step in how we
get rid of the quantum nature
of the electromagnetic field
when it interacts with
atoms mechanically.
OK.
So, by the way, everything
I'm telling you today--
actually, in the
first half of today--
can be found in
Atom-Photon Interaction.
Now, so this takes
care actually,
of most of the
electromagnetic field.
We come back to
that in a moment.
The next thing is we want
to use the full quantum
solution for the
atomic dipole operator,
and that means we want
to remind ourselves
of the solution of the
Optical Bloch Equations.
PROFESSOR: Now, talking about
the Optical Bloch Equations,
I just have to remind you
of what we did in class,
but I have to apologize
it's a little bit
exercise in notation.
Because in Atom-Photon
Interaction
they use a slightly
different notation then
you find in other sources.
On the other hand, I think
I've nicely prepared for you,
and I give you the
translation table.
In Atom-Photon Interaction,
they regard the Bloch vector,
and we have introduced
the components, u, v,
and w, as a
fictitious spin, 1/2.
Therefore, you find with this
kind of old-fashioned letters,
Sx, Sy, Sc, in
Atom-Photon Interaction.
The other thing, if
you open the book,
Atom-Photon Interaction
is that their operators,
density matrix-- the atomic
density matrix-- sigma,
and sigma head.
One is in the rotating frame,
and one is in the lab frame.
So we have to go back
and forth to do that,
but the result is
fairly trivial.
So this is simply
the definition.
First of all, the density
matrix is the full description
of the atomic
system, but instead
of dealing with matrix
elements of the density matrix,
it's more convenient
for two level system
to use a fictitious spin
or the Bloch vector.
So the important equation--
the are the Optical Block
Equations-- is the
equation A20 in API.
And it's simply the first
order differential equation
for the components
of the Optical Bloch
vector, u v, and w.
Notation is as usual,
the laser detuning,
delta L. Omega 1 is the
[INAUDIBLE] frequency.
And this is the
parametrization of
the classical electromagnetic
field which drives the system.
Now, this equation is
identical to the equation
we discussed in the unit on
solutions of Optical Bloch
Equations.
We just called the
[INAUDIBLE] frequency, g,
delta L was called delta.
And then, vectors
of 2r was confusing.
The components, [? r,x,y,z, ?]
are two times u, v, w.
And the reason for
that is some people
prefer that it
represents spin 1/2,
so they want to
normalize things to 1/2.
Or if you want to
have unit vectors,
your throw in a vector of two.
But that is all, so if you're
confused about a vector of two,
it's exactly this substitution
which has been made.
So these are the Optical Bloch
Equations, and what we need now
is the solution.
What we need now is the
solution for the dipole moment,
because it is the
dipole moment which
is responsible for
the mechanical forces.
The dipole operator is, of
course, the non-diagonal matrix
elements, the coherencies
of the density matrix.
So all we want to take now
from the previous unit,
the expectation value of
the dipole moment, which
is nothing else than the trace
of the statistical operator
with the operator of
the dipole moment.
At this point, just
to guide you through,
we go from the lab frame-- from
the density matrix in the lab
frame-- to the density
matrix in the rotating frame,
and this is when the
laser frequency appears,
is into the i omega l t.
And therefore, we want
to describe things
in the lab frame.
If you use the u and v
part of the Optical Bloch
vector obtained in the rotating
frame, in the lab frame
everything rotates at
the laser frequency.
If you drive an atom, if you
drive a harmonic oscillator
with a laser frequency,
the harmonic oscillator
responds at the laser frequency,
not at the atomic frequency.
We discussed that a while ago.
So therefore, the
dipole moment oscillates
at the laser frequency.
And their two components, u
and v-- since our laser field
was parametrized by definition--
epsilon 0 times cosine omega t.
We have now nicely separated,
through the Optical Bloch
vector the in phase part
of the dipole moment,
and the in quadrature
phase of dipole moment.
If you didn't pay attention
what I said the last five
minutes, that's OK, you
can just start here,
saying the expectation value
of the dipole moment oscillates
with a laser frequency.
And as for any harmonic
oscillator, or harmonic
oscillator type system,
there is one component
which is in phase,
and one component
which is in quadrature.
Fast forward.
OK.
And you know from any
harmonic oscillator,
when it comes to
the absorbed power,
that it's only the
quadrature component which
absorbs the power.
And you can immediately
see that when
we say-- just use what
is written in black
now-- the energy is nothing
else than the charge
times the displacement.
When we divide by
delta t, you'll
find that the absorbed
power is the electric field
times the derivative
of the dipole moment.
Well, if you ever
reach over one cycle,
we are only interested
in d dot, which
oscillates with cosine omega t.
But that means since it's d dot,
d oscillates with sine omega t.
And this was the in
quadrature component, v.
So it is only the part, v, of
the Optical Bloch vector which
is responsible for
exchanging energy
with the electromagnetic field.
And we can also, by dividing
by the energy of a photon,
find out what is the
number of absorbed photons.
But we did that already when
we discussed Optical Bloch
Equations.
OK, so that was our look back
on the Optical Bloch Equation,
the solution for the
oscillating dipole moment,
and now we are ready to
put everything together.
So we want to know the force.
The force, using Heisenberg's
Equation of Motion
for the momentum derivative
is the expectation value
of the operator, which is the
gradient of the Hamiltonian.
OK.
So now we have to take the
gradient of the Hamiltonian.
This is the only
expression, actually,
today, I would've liked to just
write it down, and build it
up piece by piece.
But let me step you through.
We want to take the gradient.
The dipole operator of the atom
does not have an r dependence,
it's just x on the
atom, wherever it is.
But the gradient with respect
to the center of mass position
from the atoms comes
from the operator
of the electromagnetic field.
So in other words,
what this involves
is the gradient of the
operator of the fully quantized
electromagnetic field.
But we have already written
at the electromagnetic field
as an external
electromagnetic field--
classical electromagnetic
field-- plus a vacuum
fluctuations.
But the vacuum
fluctuations are symmetric.
There is nothing which
tells vacuum fluctuations
what is left and what is right.
So therefore, the
derivative only
acts on the classical
electromagnetic field.
So this is how we
have now, you know,
we first throw out
the coherent state,
and now we throw out
the vacuum state.
And therefore, it is
only the classical part
of the electromagnetic
field which
is responsible for the forces.
Now we make one way assumption
which greatly simplifies it.
R is the center of mass
position of the atom,
and we have to take the
electromagnetic field
as the center of mass position.
And if the atom is
localized-- wave packet
with a long [? dipole ?]
wave-- we sort of
have to involve the
atomic wave function
when we evaluate this operator
of the electromagnetic field.
However, if the
atom is very well
localized-- you would
actually want the atom
to be localized to within
an optical wave length--
then, under those
circumstances, you
can replace the
parameter, r, which
is a position of the atom, by
the center of the atomic wave
packet.
So therefore, the
kind of wave nature
of the atoms--
which means the atom
is smeared out-- as long as
this wave packet is small,
compared to the
wave lengths, you
can just evaluate the
electromagnetic field
at the center of
the wave packet.
This assumption
requires-- since the scale
of the electromagnetic field
is set by the wave lengths--
this requires that the
atom is localized better
than an optical wave length.
And that would mean
that the energy
of the atom, or the
temperature, has
to be larger than
the recoil in it.
And if you're localized the,
to within a wave length,
your momentum spread is larger,
by Heisenberg's Uncertainty
Relation than h bar
k, and that means
your energy is larger
than the recoil energy.
So if you want to have
a description or light
forces in that limit, you may
have to revise this point.
But for most of laser cooling,
when you start with a hot cloud
and cool it down to
micro-Kelvin temperatures,
this is very [INAUDIBLE].
Colin?
AUDIENCE: Vacuum field
doesn't contribute
in sort of in the sense that
the expectation value is zero.
But wouldn't the rms
value be non-zero?
So what's the--?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
I mean, in the end, you
will see that in a moment,
when we talk about
cooling limits,
fluctuations, spontaneous
emission, provides heating.
It doesn't contribute
if you want
to find the expectation
value for the force.
The vacuum and the
fluctuations-- I mean,
that's also logical-- the
vacuum has only fluctuations,
it has no net force.
But the fluctuation's heat.
And for heating, it
will be very important.
But we'll come to that
in a little bit later.
AUDIENCE: So what
is [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If the
light is squeezed, yes.
That's a whole different thing.
We really assumed here that the
light is in a coherent state.
Now--
AUDIENCE: The transformation
that we had [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you know,
you can squeeze the vacuum.
And then it's squeezed.
But there's so few
photons, you can't really
laser cool with that.
So the only way how you
could possibly laser cool
is if you take the squeezed
vacuum, and displace it.
So now you have, instead
of a little circle,
which is a coherent
state, you have
an ellipse, which is displaced.
I haven't done the
math-- maybe that would
be an excellent homework
assignment for the next time I
teach the course--
you could probably
show that the displacement
operator, which is now
displacing the squeezed vacuum,
again can be transformed
into a c number,
and the ellipse this
squeezed vacuum
fluctuation-- the ellipse has
an even symmetry, has an 180
degree rotation symmetry.
And I could imagine that it will
not contribute to the force.
So in other words, if you have
a displaced, squeezed vacuum,
my gut feeling is nothing
would change here.
But what would change,
aren't the fluctuations,
but which would possibly
change is the heating.
OK, so we within
those approximations,
Heisenberg's Equation
of Motion for the force
becomes an equation
for the acceleration
for the atomic wave packet.
And it involves now, two terms.
One is the atomic
dipole moment as
obtained from the
Optical Bloch Equations,
and the other one
is nothing else
than the gradient of
the classical part
of the electromagnetic field.
And with that we are pretty
much at the equations which
you looked at in your
homework assignment, which
was a classical model
for the light force.
Because this part is
completely classical,
and the only quantum
aspect which we still have
is that we evaluate
the dipole moment,
not necessarily, it's just a
driven harmonic oscillator.
When we take the
Optical Bloch Equations,
we will also find saturation
a two-level system can
be saturated, whereas a
harmonic oscillator can never
be saturated.
So let me just repeat,
so this is completely
classical except
for the expectation
value for the dipole moment.
But for no excitation,
of course-- and we've
discussed it many, many
times-- a two-level system
is nothing else for
weak excitation,
than a weakly excited
harmonic oscillator.
So then we are
completely classical.
But we want to discuss
also saturation and that's
been the Optical Bloch
Equations, of course, come
in very handy.
OK.
Next approximation,
we want to know--
approximate-- the dipole
moment-- the expectation
value of the dipole moment--
with the steady state solution.
The steady state solution--
analytic expression--
we just plug it in, and you
can have a wonderful discussion
about light forces.
The question is, are
we allowed to do that?
Now I hope you'll remember
that's actually one reason why
I did that when we discussed
the master equation.
And we discussed an [? atomic ?]
[? cavity. ?] I introduced
to you the adiabatic
elimination of variables.
We adiabatically
eliminated [? of dipole ?]
matrix elements.
Whenever you have something
which relaxes sufficiently
fast, and you're not interested
in this short time scale,
you can always say, I
replace this quantity
by its steady state value.
Steady state with regard to
the slowly changing parameter.
And we want to do
exactly the same here.
So let me just translate.
It's the same idea,
exactly the same idea,
but let me translate.
If an atom moves, we have two
aspects, two times [? case. ?]
One is the motion of the atom.
The atom may change
its velocity.
The atom may move from an
area of strong electric field
to an area of weak
electric field.
But this is really all that
is related to the motion,
to the change of momentum
of a heavy object.
But now inside the atoms,
you play with the, you know,
Bloch vector, excited state.
If the electric
field is higher, you
have a larger population
in the excited
state than in the ground state.
But this usually adjusts with
the damping time of gamma,
with a spontaneous
emission rate.
And that's usually very fast.
So you can make
the assumption when
an atom moves to a changing
electric field, at every point
in the electric field,
it very, very quickly--
the dipole moment--
assumes the steady state
solution for the
local electric field.
And this would now be called
an adiabatic elimination
of the dynamics of the atom.
And we simply replace
the expectation value
for the dipole moment by
the steady state solution
of the Optical Bloch Equations.
Well, this is, of
course, an approximation.
And I want to take
this approximation
and who you what
simple conclusions we
can draw from that.
But I also want
you to know, I mean
this is what I focus
off in this course,
to sort of think about
them and get a feel where
those approximations break down.
So this approximation requires
that the internal motion, that
this, you know,
two-level physics,
that the internal
density matrix,
it has a relaxation
rate of gamma.
Whereas the external
motion, we will actually
see that very soon when we talk
about molasses and damping,
has a characteristic
damping time which
is one over the recoil energy.
The recoiled energy
involves the mass.
The heavier the object, the
slower is the damping time.
It has all the right scaling.
And you will actually
see in the data
today, that we will naturally
obtain this as the time scale
over which atomic
motions is changing.
So, is that approximation,
this hierarchy of time scales,
is that usually fulfilled?
It is fulfilled in almost all
of the atoms you are working on.
For instance, in sodium, the
ratio of those two time scales
is 400.
But if you push it,
you will find examples
like, helium in the
triplets statement--
metastable helium in the triplet
state-- where the two time
scales are comparable.
Helium is a very light,
so therefore, it's
faster for a light atom to
change its motion by exchanging
momentum with
electromagnetic field.
And at the same time,
the transition in helium
is narrower, and
therefore slower.
So for metastable helium, the
two time scales are comparable.
| if you really want to do
quantitative experiments
with metastable helium, you may
need a more complicated theory.
But, of course, if something
is sort of simple in one case,
the richer situation
provides another opportunity
for research.
And I know, for instance,
Hal Metcalf, a good colleague
and friend of mine,
he focused for a while
on studying laser cooling
of metastable helium,
because he was
interested what happens
if those simple approximations
don't work anymore?
Then the internal motion
and the external motion
becomes sort of more entangled.
You have to treat them together,
you cannot separate them
by a hierarchy of time scales.
Any questions about that?
OK, now we have done, you know,
everything which is complicated
has been approximated away now.
And now we have a
very simple result.
So I'm pretty much
repeating what
you have done your homework,
but now with expressions which
have still the quantum character
of the Optical Bloch Equations.
So let's assume that we have
an external electric field.
it's parametrized like that, and
at this point, by providing it
like this, I leave it open
whether we have a standing
wave-- if you have a
traveling wave, of course,
we have a phase
factor, kr, here--
if you have a standing wave, we
don't have this phase factor.
So I have parametrized
the electromagnetic field
in such a way that we can
derive a general expression.
And then we will discuss what
happens in a traveling wave,
and what happens
in a standing wave.
I make one more assumption here,
namely that the polarization
is independent of position.
I'm just lazy if
I take derivatives
of the electric field.
I want to take a derivative
with the amplitude
of the electric
field, and I want
to take a derivative
of the phase
of the electromagnetic field.
I do not want to take a
derivative of the polarization.
Of course, what I'm
throwing out here,
is all of the interesting
cooling mechanisms
of polarization
gradient cooling, when
the polarization
of the light field
spirals around in
three dimensions.
We'll talk a little bit
about that later on,
I just want to keep
things simple here.
OK, so now if you
take the gradient
of the electromagnetic
field, finally, we
have approximated
everything which
complicates our life away.
And we have two terms.
One is the gradient
x on the amplitude
of the electromagnetic field,
or the gradient x on the phase.
And since we have taken
a derivative, when
we take the derivative
of the phase,
because of the chain rule,
the cosine changes into sine.
So therefore, the gradient
of the electromagnetic field
has a cosine in phase and
an in quadrature component.
And now, for the force,
we have to multiply
this with the dipole moment.
And, of course, we
will average over
one cycle of the
electromagnetic wave.
And, of course, that's
what we discussed.
There's is a u and v component
of the Bloch vector, which
gives rise to an in phase
and in quadrature component
of the dipole moment.
And now, if you combine--
if you multiply--
the gradient of the electric
field with the dipole moment,
and average.
The cosine part goes
with the cosine part,
the sine part goes
with the sine part,
and the cos terms average out.
So therefore, we have
the simple result
that we have two
contributions to the [? old ?]
mechanical force of light.
And the u component--
the in phase component--
of the dipole moment goes with
the amplitude of the gradient.
And the in quadrature
component goes
with the gradient of the phase.
So in other words, when
it comes to light forces,
the cosine component
and the sine component
of the dipole moment
talk, actually,
to two different
quantities associated
with the electromagnetic field.
It's just in phase
and in quadrature.
OK.
Now I just have to tell you
a few definitions and names.
This component, which goes
with the in phase component,
is called the reactive force.
Whereas the other one is
called the dissipative force.
The name, of course, comes
that if you have a harmonic
oscillator, the component
which oscillates in quadrature
absorbs directly energy,
whereas the in phase component
does not absorb energy.
I'll leave it for
a little bit later
in our discussion how you
can have a force and not
exchange energy.
That's a little
bit a mystery when
we talk about cooling
with a reactive force.
We will have to scrutinize
what happens with energy,
because at least
in the most basic,
the in phase component
of the oscillating system
does not extract energy from
the electromagnetic field.
So maybe just
believe that for now,
and we will scrutinize it later.
Any questions?
Am I going too fast?
Am I going too slow?
Does it mean about right?
OK.
So we have now obtained the
reactive force, which is also
called the dipole force
or stimulated force,
and the dissipated
force, which is also
called the spontaneous force.
The next thing is
purely nomenclature.
We want to introduce
appropriate vectors
which point along the
gradient of the phase,
and which point along the
gradient of the amplitude.
And this is done here.
So we want to say
that the reactive
and the dissipative
force are written
in a very sort of similar
way, but the one off them
points in the direction
of a vector, alpha,
the other one in the
direction of a vector, beta.
The beta vector is the
gradient of the phase.
If the phase is kr, the
gradient of the phase
is simply k, the k vector
of the electromagnetic wave.
So that will come in handy
in just a few seconds.
Whereas the reactive
force points
into the direction of the
gradient of the amplitude,
but we never want to talk
about electromagnetic field
amplitude.
For us, we always use the
electric field in terms of you
parametrize the Rabi frequency.
The Rabi frequency is
really the atomic unit
of the electric field.
So therefore, this
vector which involves now
the gradient of the amplitude,
becomes a normalized gradient
of the Rabi frequency.
So these are the two fundamental
light forces, the reactive
and the dissipative force.
OK.
Now we are going to have a
quick look at those two forces.
So therefore, I'm now
discussing the two
simple, but already
very characteristic
cases for those forces.
One is we want to look at
a plane travelling wave,
and then we want to look
at a pure standing wave.
And the beauty of it is in
a plane travelling wave,
you've a plain wave, the
amplitude of the electric field
is constant everywhere,
it just oscillates.
And therefore, this
alpha vector is zero.
And in a few minutes, we
look at this standing wave,
and in the standing wave,
the beta vector is zero.
So the travelling wave and the
standing wave allows us now
to look at the two forces
separately in two physical
situations which are--
as you will see later--
highly relevant for experiments.
Well, I don't think I have to
tell anybody in this room--
maybe except some
people who take
the course for
[? Brett's ?] requirement--
that standing waves
or optical lattices
are common in all labs.
And similar,
traveling wave beams
are used, for instance, for
decelerating atomic beams.
So we illustrate
the two forces now,
but we already discussing two
experimentally very important
geometries.
OK, plain travelling waves.
I mean, I just really plug
now the electromagnetic field
for plain travelling wave,
I plug it into the equations
above.
The important thing is--
and which simplifies things
a lot-- is that the
alpha vector is zero.
The amplitude of
the plain wave is--
that's what a plain
wave is-- constant.
And the beta vector is the
gradient of the Rabi frequency
is just the k
vector of the light.
So therefore, the dissipative
or spontaneous light force
was the Rabi frequency times
the v component of the Optical
Bloch vector times h bar k.
And this has a very
simple interpretation
because the steady state
solution of the Optical Bloch
Equation is nothing else than
gamma times the excited state
population.
And since the excited state
scatters, or emits photons
at a rate, gamma,
this is nothing else
than the number of
absorbed emitted
scattered photons times h bar k.
We are in steady state
here, so the number
of photons which are emitted
into all space, into the vacuum
has to be the number
of photons which
has been absorbed
into the laser beam.
So therefore, the interpretation
here is very simple,
you have a laser beam.
Every time the atom
absorbs a photon, it
receives a recoil
transfer, h bar k.
Now, afterwards, the
photon is scattered,
but the scattering is
symmetric, and does not
impart the force onto the atom.
And this is what we
discussed earlier.
The quantum part of the
electromagnetic field
is symmetric.
And here, we see sort of
what it means visually.
Spontaneous emission
goes equally
probable in opposite direction,
and there is no net force,
but there is heating
as we discussed later.
So we can plug in the solution--
the steady state solution--
from the Optical Bloch Equation.
That's our Lorentzian.
We have discussed power
broadening already
when we discussed the
Optical Bloch Equation.
And, of course,
I just remind you
if you saturate the system with
a strong laser power, what you
can obtain is that
half of the population
is in the excited state,
and half of the population
is in the ground state.
Under those circumstances,
do you get the maximum force.
And the maximum
spontaneous force
is the momentum per photon
times the maximum rate at which
a two-level atom
can scatter photons.
So that's, in a
nutshell, I think
all you have to know about
the spontaneous light force
as far as the
force is concerned.
But we still have to discuss
the heating associated
with a spontaneous force, which
are the force fluctuations.
Questions?
Well, then let's do
a similar discussion
with reactive forces.
Which is a little bit richer
because, well, you will see.
So a standing wave
is parametrized here.
We only have an alpha
vector, not a beta vector
now, because
everything is in phase,
there is no phase phi of r.
So therefore, there is
no dissipative force,
the only force is
a reactive force.
Since the reactive
force depends only on u,
there is no exchange of energy.
So that raises the question,
what is really going on it is
only the reactive part with
u, how can the atom really--
How can the motion change if
it cannot exchange energy?
Well, we'll come to that
in different pieces.
The one part I want to
sort of discuss here
is that you should--
I want to show you
that at the level
of our discussion
we can already understand
that the atom is actually
doing a redistribution
of energy and momentum.
Well, if I only hold
onto my standing wave,
there is no energy exchange
because the atom is always
in phase with the
standing wave--
the atomic dipole-- which is
this one [INAUDIBLE] force.
But I can now do what
everybody does in the lab.
We generate the standing wave
as a superposition of two
travelling waves.
And if I have a superposition
of two traveling waves,
there is a point in space where
the phases of the traveling
waves are the same.
Then one phase is
advanced in phase,
and the other side one of the
waves is lagging in phase.
And for pedagogical reasons,
I pick the point where the two
travelling waves are 90
degree phase shifted.
OK.
Now the situation is that
we have our electric field
and what is responsible for the
reactive light force is the u
part of the dipole moment of
the Optical Bloch vector, which
oscillates in phase.
But nobody prevents me from
analyzing it with respect
to E1 and E2.
And so if I ask now, I
say, I have one laser beam.
I have another laser beam.
And if you want, after the
laser beams have crossed,
you can put in two photo-diodes,
and you can not only
ask, what happens
to the standing
wave, you can also ask, what
happens to each traveling wave?
Are photons absorbed?
Or what happens?
And now, what is obvious
is if you have an harmonic
oscillator, and you have an
oscillating dipole moment,
if the dipole moment
is withing 0 and 180
degrees with a dry
field, you absorb power.
If it is in the two
other quadrants,
it emits, or delivers power.
And now you see, that
we are in a situation--
which I've peak here-- where one
travelling wave loses energy,
and the other traveling
wave gains energy.
And there is a
classic experiment,
which was done by Bill Phillips
a while ago-- he had atoms
in an optical lattice,
and they were sloshing.
And she could really measure
that when the atoms were
accelerated this way, one of
the laser beams gained power,
and the other one lost power.
So while the atoms
where sloshing
in momentum space, the power
between the two laser beams
was distributed back and forth.
So this is the character
of the dissipative force,
that it redistributes momentum
and energy between the two
traveling waves.
Any questions?
Boris?
AUDIENCE: But if
there's a net change
in the patterns of
motion, the energy still
has to come from somewhere.
Right?
Can you make that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This
question has bothered
in many different iterations.
And at some point, I found a
very, very easy answer to it.
And this is one of your
homework assignments
for homework number 10.
There's a very
simple example where
you will realize where
the energy comes.
What happens is,
in steady state,
if everything is
stationary, of course,
there can't be an exchange.
But, if you're for
instance, saying--
and I give you no part of the
solution-- if you have atoms,
and they are attracted
by the dipole force,
there's a strong laser beam and
the atoms are accelerated in,
and you're now asking, where
does the energy come from?
Because all of what the
atoms do, at least according
to what I'm telling
you, they redistribute
photons of energy, h
bar omega, into photons
of energy, h bar omega.
So where does the
energy come from?
You have to go higher in
the approximation here
to understand where
the energy comes from.
Let me just tell
you one thing, this
is actually something which
I've encountered several times.
And it can be really
confusing, I've
really proven to mathematically
the this is false.
So in this level of treatment,
with these very simple
concepts, we correctly
obtained the optical force.
But if you're now asking,
where does the energy go?
You have to go deeper.
And, for instance,
what happens is
if you take a cloud of
atoms, and the cloud of atoms
moves in an out
of a laser beam--
just think of it as
center of mass dipole
oscillations of a Boson-Einstein
condensate in an optical dipole
trap-- what happens is when
the atoms move in and out,
they actually act as a phase
modulator for the laser beam.
The index of the refraction of
your laser beam is changing.
So therefore-- and we
don't deal with that
when he replace the
electromagnetic field by a c
number-- your laser beam, when
the atoms move in will actually
show a frequency modulation.
And you will find-- and it's a
wonderful homework assignment,
I'm pretty proud
that we created it,
and that it works
out so easily-- you
will find that the kinetic
energy of the atoms
is exactly compensated
by the energy shift
the photons which have
passed through the atoms.
But I'm giving you a
very advanced answer.
It's often very difficult
if you have a simple picture
for the force to figure out
what happens to the energy.
Actually, let me give
you the other example.
When we have the
previous example,
where we have atoms and
we have a laser beam
which cools with a
radiation pressure.
This was our previous example.
Where does the energy go?
I have a wonderful correct--
within the assumptions--
an exact expression
for the force.
Where does the energy go?
The atoms have a
counter-propagating laser beam.
They scatter photons
with this rate.
Every time they scatter
a photon, they slow down
by h bar k.
They lose energy.
We have a complete
description what
happens in the momentum
picture and in forces.
But where does the energy come?
Or where does the energy go?
The energy where
the atoms have lost?
AUDIENCE: They absorb a
slightly high frequency
with a Doppler shift.
And then slow down
and then re-release
a photon with
slightly lower energy.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So in that case, it
actually depends which way.
When the atom loses
energy, the energy
goes into blue-shifted photons.
I'm just saying, in order to
address the question, what
happens to the energy, we have
to bring in our physics, which
we didn't even consider
to address here.
It is now the physics of the
spontaneously emitted photons.
We said for the force,
spontaneous emission vacuum
fluctuations can be eliminated.
But if you try to understand
where does the energy go,
we have to go to those
terms, and we even
find the physics of Doppler
shifts, which we didn't put in,
which we didn't
even assume here.
But, of course, it has
to be self consistent.
So therefore, you sometimes have
to go to very different physics
which isn't even
covered by your equation
to see the flip
side of the coin.
One side is forces,
which are very simple,
but the other side of the
coin can be more difficult.
We'll actually come back to
that when we talk about cooling
[INAUDIBLE].
Cooling with a stimulated force.
How can a stimulated force
cool, because it's all u.
Well, we'll get there.
And it will again
be-- the energy--
will be extracted through
spontaneous emission
from all those side
[INAUDIBLE] and all that.
So we have to trace
down the energy,
and we successfully
will do that.
But energy can be subtle.
Forces are simple.
Other questions?
Actually, since
I'm in chatty mood,
when I explained to you
where the energy goes
in a dipole trap-- that it's a
phase modulation for the laser
beam-- I have been using
optical dipole traps
in my laboratory for
many, many years,
before I really figured
out where the energy goes.
And I'm almost
99% certain if you
go to DAMOP, and ask
some of the experts
on cooling and trapping,
and ask them to figure out
this problem, most of
the people will not
be able to give you this answer.
I've actually not found the
answer in any standard textbook
of laser cooling, until I
eventually found it myself
and posted and prepared it
as a homework assignment.
So many, many people may
not be able to give you
the correct answer,
where does the energy go
when atoms slosh around
in a dipole trap.
Try it out at DAMOP,
it may be fun.
OK.
So back to the simple
physics of forces.
We don't need to
understand the energy,
because we know the forces,
but we'll come back to that.
So we have the reactive force.
The reactive force
is written here.
What have we done?
Well, you remember
the alpha vector
was the gradient of
the Rabi frequency,
and we have to multiply with the
u component of the steady state
solution of the
Optical Bloch Equation.
Here it is, just put together.
It's a nice expression.
There are two things you
should know about it.
The first one is
that you can actually
write this force exactly as
the gradient of a potential.
So there is a dipole
potential, and is
exactly this dipole
potential which
is used as a trapping potential
when you have dipole traps.
Probably 99% of you use
dipole traps in the limit
where the detuning is large.
And then the logarithm of
1 plus x simply becomes x,
and you have the simple
expression you are using.
But in a way, this
is remarkable.
The dipole force can be
derived from a potential,
even if the detuning
is small, and you
have a hell of a lot of
spontaneous scattering, which
is usually not regarded as being
due to conservative potential.
So this expression,
that the reactive force
is a gradient of a potential,
even applies to a situation
where gamma spontaneous
scattering [INAUDIBLE]
And you're not
simply in-- and this
is what this last term is--
in the perturbative limit
of the AC Stark Effect.
OK.
That's number one you should
know about this expression.
The second thing is if you
look at this expression,
the question is, what is
the maximum reactive force?
We talked about the maximum
spontaneous, or dissipative
force, which is h
bar k, the momentum
of a photon times gamms over 2.
What is the maximum
force you can get out
of the reactive force?
Well, of course, if you
want a lot of force,
you want to use a
lot of laser power.
Therefore, you want to
use a high Rabi frequency.
And now, if you want to use
your laser power wisely,
the question is, how should
you pick the detuning?
And you realize if you
pick the detuning small,
there is a prefector
which goes to zero,
but if you pick your
detuning extremely large,
the denominator kills you.
And well, if you analyze it
and or stare at this expression
for more than a
second, you realize
that the optimum detuning
is when the detuning is
on the order of
the Rabi frequency.
And if you plug
that in, you find
that under those
optimum conditions,
the reactive force
can be written again
as the momentum of
a photon-- it must
be, the momentum of the
photon is the unit of force,
the quantum of force,
which has to appear--
but not the frequency
is not gamma,
but it is the Rabi frequency.
So the picture you
should sort of have
is that under those
situations, just
assume the standing wave
consists of two traveling
waves, and the atom
is Rabi flopping.
But it is Rabi flopping
in a way that it goes up
by taking a photon
from one laser beam,
and then it goes down
by emitting the photon
into the other laser beam.
So during each
Rabi flux cycle, it
exchanges a momentum
of 2 h bar k
with the electromagnetic field.
So therefore, the reactive
force-- the stimulated force--
never saturates if you increase
the Rabi frequency-- depending,
of course, on your detuning,
but if you choose the detuning
correctly-- you can
get a force which
is just going
further and further.
Questions?
Yes, Jen?
AUDIENCE: Is this the same
concept as the Raman constants,
except that the frequencies
are just the same?
Or is it just a--
PROFESSOR: It is
a Raman process.
Actually, everything is
a Raman process here.
Because in laser
cooling, in everything
which involves the mechanical--
the motion, the external degree
freedom of the atoms-- we have
an atom in one momentum state.
We go-- light scattering always
has to involve the excited
state-- and then we go down
to a different momentum state.
So therefore, laser
cooling is nothing else
than Raman processes in the
external degree of freedom
of the atom.
You may be used to
[INAUDIBLE] Raman process
more when you start in
one hyperfine state,
or for molecules in one
vibration rotation state,
and you go to another
one, but, well,
for vibration, and
rotational states,
and hyperfine states of it,
Raman is used all the time.
I usually used it also
for the external motion,
because I think it
clearly brings out
common features between
all those different Raman
processes.
So you can actually say that the
reactive force is a stimulated
Raman process between two
momentum states, where
both legs are stimulated
by laser beams.
In a standing wave, it
would be-- the two legs--
would be stimulated by the
two travelling wave components
of the standing wave.
Whereas the dissipative force
is spontaneous Raman process,
where one leg is driven by
the laser, and the other one
comes with spontaneous emission.
Nicky?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when the atoms
slow down, the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the
spontaneously emitted photon?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
I'm just thinking
of actually the
stimulated force.
Because the atom
must be stimulated.
[INAUDIBLE] I'm
confused how when
the energy of the emitted photon
must be slightly different
due to the phase modulation?
[INAUDIBLE] stimulated emission
can be added to the frequency?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I mean we had the
discussion after [INAUDIBLE]
question, if you go up and
down, and you are stimulated,
you go up in a stimulated
way, you go down
in a stimulated way,
and both laser fields
which stimulate the transition
have the same frequency, omega,
you would actually see that
there is no energy exchange.
So at our current
level of description
we have described where
the force comes from,
but we don't understand
yet where the energy goes,
or where the energy comes from.
And this is really
more sophisticated,
and I don't want to sort
of continue the discussion.
We will encounter one
situation, and this
is in the [INAUDIBLE]
atom picture, where
we will discuss in a week
or so, sisyphus cooling.
And we will find
out that there is
symmetries in the mono-triplet.
So again, we will find
the missing energy
in spontaneous emission.
But if you don't have
spontaneous emission,
if you just have atoms
moving in an optical lattice
without spontaneous emission,
it is really what I said,
the phase modulation.
And I would probably
ask you at this point
to do the homework
assignment, and maybe
have a discussion
afterwards, because then you
know exactly what
I'm talking about.
Does it at least-- You can take
that as a preliminary answer.
So these are the
two limiting cases.
One is spontaneous
emission, and the other one
is phase modulation at
a certain frequency.
One can be sustained
in steady state,
you can spontaneously
emit in sort of an atom
goes to a standing wave,
and this is sustainable.
Whereas the phase modulation
thing is actually a transient.
It's an oscillation
which is added in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You're adding the force
to the other one [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, actually--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If that helps
you, but it's the following.
I would sometimes
say you know, I
like sort of intuitive
explanations of quantum
physics.
Let's assume I'm an atom.
I'm in [INAUDIBLE]
standing wave.
And you don't know it yet,
but I do sisyphus cooling.
By just exchanging photons,
a stimulated force,
I'm actually cooling.
And you would say,
how is it possible?
Because all the photon exchanges
involve the same photon,
the same energy.
How can I get rid of energy?
And I think what really
happens is the following,
the atoms can lose
momentum without energy,
but due to Heisenberg's
Uncertainty Relationship
this is possible.
So the atom is first taking
care of its momentum--
is losing momentum--
by stimulated force,
and eventually,
before it's too late,
it has to do some
spontaneous emission where
it is paying back it debts
in energy to Heisenberg.
So and of course, after a
certain time, everything is OK.
The force was provided
by exchanging photons
of identical frequency.
And the energy is provided by an
occasional spontaneous emission
event, using one
of the [INAUDIBLE].
So everything is there.
Everything is a perfect
picture, but you
have to sort of, in
this description,
allow a certain uncertainty
that the force is
the exchange of
identical photons,
and the energy
balance is reconciled
in spontaneous emission.
And on any longer time scale
there are enough events
that the balance is
perfectly matched.
But if you would
take the position,
no, this is not possible.
You know, the atom can only-- I
mean, it's sort of in diagrams.
It's not that one diagram
which scatters a photon
has to conserve energy.
You have a little bit of time.
You have Heisenberg's
uncertainty time
to make sure that
another diagram jumps
in, and reconciles
energy conservation.
That's at least my way
of looking into it,
but it's a very maybe, my
personal interpretation
of how all these diagrams
and photon scattering
events work together.
OK.
Let's do something simpler now.
So I've explained to you
the dissipative force,
the reactive force,
and in the next unit
I want to show you
simply applications
of the spontaneous force.
In every experiment
on cold atoms,
the spontaneous force
is center stage.
It is necessary to
slow down atomic beams.
It provides molasses, which
is the colling of atoms
to micro-Kelvin temperature,
and the spontaneous force
is also responsible for
the Magneto-optical trap.
So what I want to
do here is, again,
by showing you the
relevant equations, how
the spontaneous force, which
we have just discussed,
how these spontaneous
force leads to those three
applications.
So this is one of the
most experimental sections
of this course, because this
equation has it all in it.
And I just want to show you how
this equation can be applied
to three different important
experimental geometries.
OK.
So this is our equation.
It has the momentum
transfer per photon.
It has the maximum scatter
rate, gamma over two.
And then, here, it has
the Lorentzian line shape.
And the important thing is
when we talk about molasses
and beam slowing is that
the detuning is the laser
detuning and the
Doppler detuning.
So the velocity
dependence enters now
the spontaneous force through
the detuning in the Lorentzian
denominator, and it enters
through the Doppler effect.
So you can pretty
much say it like this,
if you have a bunch
of laser beam,
and slow and cool your atoms,
how can the lasers do the job?
Well, they measure the
velocity of the atoms
through the Doppler shift.
And if is the Doppler
shift which tells
the laser beams what
to do, so to speak.
And this is how
laser cooling works.
So just as an
experimentalist, you
should actually know
what the scale is.
If somebody asked
you, how strong
is the spontaneous
scattering force?
Well, a way to connect
it with real time
units-- with real
life units-- is,
what is the maximum
deceleration?
Well, this is 10 to
the 5 G. You can ask,
is 10 to the 5 G a lot?
Or not?
Well, for an astronaut,
it would be a lot.
It would.
No living organism can
sustain 10 to the 5 G.
But I'm really surprised
when I did this calculation.
When you compare it
to the electric force
on an ionized atom,
the same force,
which is provided by the
spontaneous light force,
would be provided
by an electric field
of one millivolt per centimeter.
So it's not easy if you
have a stainless steel
chamber to avoid
petch effects, which
create those electric fields.
And if you've a
battery with 9 volt,
a centimeter apart--
just a 9 volt battery--
would accelerate an ion
four orders of magnitude
faster than your beloved
strong spontaneous light force.
So in that sense,
10 to the 5 G is
a lot in the macroscopic
world, but if you
would look at microscopic
forces-- which are often
electric forces--
it's absolutely tiny.
And sometimes I say,
the fact that you
can do 100 kilovolt
per centimeter,
that you can make
electric forces which
are seven, eight, or
nine, orders of magnitude
stronger, that's actually
the reason why ion traps were
invented before trapping
of neutral particles.
So some developments
in the field
of trapping particles--
and eventually
laser cooling them-- it
first started with ion traps,
and then it proceeded
to neutral atoms.
And the reason is
the ion trappers
have forces at
their disposal which
are eight or nine orders
of magnitude stronger.
OK.
Optical molasses.
I know some of you will
hate it, because I've just
explained to you that
in a standing wave,
we don't have any
spontaneous light force,
all we have is the reactive
force, the stimulated force,
because it is the
u, the in phase
oscillation of the atomic
dipole operator which
is responsible for everything.
But now I'm just, you
know, wearing another hat,
and I tell you that there is a
limit where the total force can
be regarded with some
of the two forces.
So therefore, I'm
pretending now that if you
have near resonant light
in a standing wave,
that the force in the
standing wave-- which you know
is a purely reactive
force-- can now
be written as the sum of
the two propagating waves.
And, of course, each
propagating wave
does a purely dissipative force.
That is, what I'm telling you
can be mathematically proven.
That the stimulated force
in a standing wave is equal
to the sum of the two
dissipative forces or each
travelling wave.
I just keep that
in mind whenever
you think you can
rigorously distinguish
between the dissipative force
and the stimulated force.
Keep in mind that
a standing wave--
which has only a
stimulated force,
as I rigorously proved to you--
can alternatively be described
as the sum of two
spontaneous light forces,
each of which provided by
one of the travelling waves.
Well, it sort of makes sense
in a perturbative limit.
You can just take one beam,
you can take the other beam,
and the combined effect
of the two laser beams
is higher order.
So the fact that in
some low intensity limit
this has to be valid,
is pretty clear.
Anyway, but just a
warning, if you really
want to use a stimulated force
here, you're in big trouble.
It's much, much harder
to get this result out
of the stimulated force.
Because to get a stimulated
force with velocity dependence
requires you to take
solutions of the Optical Bloch
Equations, which are not steady
state, but non-adiabatic.
So just a warning.
You can do it, if you want
with a stimulated force,
but I would strongly
advise you to first use
the simpler formalism.
You have to go to very different
approximation schemes and much
more technical
complexity if you want
to get it out of the
stimulated force.
OK.
So with that assumption,
you'll remember
we had the dissipative
force of each laser beam.
Now we have two laser beams.
We summed them up.
Because the two laser beams
come from different directions,
we have a minus sign here.
And for the same reason,
we have plus and minus sign
in the Doppler effect.
So what we have
is the following,
each force of each laser beam
has this Lorentzian envelope,
shown in black, but the other
force of the other laser beam
has the opposite sign.
And the two have
opposite Doppler shifts.
So if I add up the two black
forces, I get the red force.
And the red force is
anti-symmetric with respect
to velocity.
So therefore, in the
limit of small velocities
I get a force which is
minus alpha times v.
And this is the
force of friction.
And in a whimsical way,
people called this arrangement
of two traveling
waves Optical Molasses
because the atom
literally gets stuck
in this configuration
like a tiny ball
bearing you throw into honey.
So this is optical molasses.
Actually, I think
some of the Europeans
had to learn the
word molasses for it.
In the US, everybody
knows what molasses is.
Well, in Europe, we
know what honey is,
but molasses is not
a standard staple.
But anyway, it's
optical molasses.
OK.
Very simple result.
And, again, it's not easy to get
it out of the stimulated force.
But it's possible.
I will actually tell you
how we get cooling out
of the stimulated force
later in some limit.
AUDIENCE: Is there
[INAUDIBLE] why
this assumption of dissipative
forces is easier [INAUDIBLE]
and the stimulated force will
be made difficult [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm not
sure if there is
a simple answer why it's easier.
Well, it can't be
easier than that.
AUDIENCE: I mean, there has
to be something wrong with
our assumptions of stimulated
forces so that we cannot get
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think what happens
is what I briefly said.
To the best of my knowledge,
but I'm not 100% certain.
We have the simply
expression because we
have used the steady state
solution of the Optical Bloch
Equation.
In other words, we
have a laser beam,
and it's just the power of
the laser which tells us
how much light
scattering happens.
And we use the steady
state solution.
And we sort of have folded that
into the force for one laser
beam.
And then we have
the same package
for the other laser beam.
And we have never considered
that the two laser
beam may have some cross talk.
And this is indeed valid
for all low laser power.
However, if you want
to get cooling out
off the stimulated force, I
will show some of you later,
you can no longer use
the steady state solution
because it would
miss the effect here.
You wouldn't get any
cooling out of it.
In order to get something
which is dissipative,
out of a reactive
force-- reactive
force is by definition
not dissipative--
you need a
dissipation mechanism.
And the dissipation
mechanism is that you're not
quite steady state, there is
a relaxation time, a time lag.
The atom is not instantaneously
in its steady state solution.
It needs a little bit
of time to adjust.
And it is these time lag of
the atom which eventually gives
rise to an alpha coefficient
in the stimulated force.
AUDIENCE: So then
physically, you are,
during cooling experiments,
you can take care
that you are actually not
in the steady state limit?
PROFESSOR: What I'm telling you
is, for the spontaneous force,
we get in leading order
the effect by assuming
the steady state limit, but
if you want to get it out
of the stimulated
force, as far as I know,
you don't get it with
the steady state limit.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: If you use
different approaches--
I mean this is why you
want to pick your approach.
Sometimes you get something
already in lower order.
Sometimes you get
it in higher order.
And I think one
favorite example is
you solve this problem
about [INAUDIBLE] scattering
and Thompson scattering, pick
your Hamiltonian, d dot e,
or p minus a.
In one case, you have to work
harder than in the other case.
And I think here it's similar.
Anyway, let's just put
in-- I think that's, yeah,
we can do in the
next few minutes.
So we now want to
put in the effect
that the force fluctuates.
And that means we have heating.
Before I do that, let me just
tell you what the solution is
for force equals minus
alpha times v. Well,
it means we extract
energy out of the system
at a rate-- Well,
energy per unit time
is force times velocity.
Force times velocity is now
minus alpha times v square.
But v square is the
energy, the kinetic energy.
In other words, this
equation tells us
that the atomic motion,
the kinetic energy,
is exponentially [? damned. ?]
And if there were nothing else,
you just need two laser
beams-- optical molasses--
and you would go not just to
micro-Kelvin, but to nano-
and pico- Kelvin temperatures.
It's an exponential
decay to absolute zero.
However, we don't
each reach nano-
and pico- Kelvin
temperatures in laser cooling
because there are
other processes.
And what is important here
is spontaneous emission.
OK.
So the way you treat
spontaneous emission is
the following, every time an
atom emits spontaneously, there
is a random momentum
kick of h bar k.
If you have n photons scattered
because the momentum kicks
going random direction, they
only add up in a random box.
You get square root
N. Or if you ask,
what is the average of p square
due to spontaneously emission?
It is the momentum
of the photon squared
times the number of
scattering events.
So therefore, in the form
of a differential equation,
the heating rate, or the
derivative of-- the TEMPO
derivative-- of
p square goes now
with the number of
photons per unit
time, which is the
scattering rate.
OK.
If you would stop
here, and that's
what many people do who explain
heating in this situation,
you would miss half
of the heating,
because what you
have treated here
is only the photon transfer
and spontaneous emission.
However, there is also
fluctuation and absorption.
I mean just look at two
atoms in the [INAUDIBLE].
Kind of me and another atom.
And we both scatter photons.
On average, in the same laser
beam, we absorb in photons
and get in momentum kicks.
But there is
Poissonian statistics
how many photons I
absorb, and how many
photons my twin brother absorbs.
So therefore, due to the
randomness in absorption,
or the fluctuations
in absorption.
There is another
square root n variance
in the recoil kicks which comes
from the absorption process.
And it so happens, for
exactly that reason,
that the heating-- the
derivative of kinetic energy,
or the difference of momentum
squared due to absorption
is exactly the same
as in emission.
Well, if you now make
different assumptions,
spontaneous emission
has a dipole pattern.
And you can sort of factor on
the order of unity, depending
what the pattern of the
spontaneous emission
is, whether you make a 1D or 2D
model of spontaneous emission
that the photons can only
go in one dimension, in two
dimension, or three dimensions.
So you have to get
other prefectors,
but the picture is that without
going into numerical factors
on the order of unity, you have
fluctuations in the absorption,
you have a randomness
in spontaneous emission,
and they both
equally contribute.
So that means now the following,
that we have heating rate.
The heating rate we
just talked about.
The increase in p square.
Well, if you divide
by 2 times the mass,
it's increasing kinetic energy.
So the increase
in kinetic energy
is given by this expression.
And it is common if you
have a heating process
to introduce a
momentum diffusion
coefficient in that way.
It's just the definition.
It shows you how p square
increases per unit time.
And now we can get the cooling
limit for spontaneous emission,
namely by saying,
in steady state when
we have-- due to
photon scattering--
the same amount of heating and
the same amount of cooling,
the temperature will have
asymptotically reached
a steady state value.
The heating rate
was parametrized
by momentum diffusion
coefficient, d over m.
So this is sort of independent
of the velocity of the atom.
Whereas you'll remember
the cooling rate
was proportional to
the energy because it
was an exponential
approach to zero energy.
So therefore, when we have the
heating equals the cooling,
we have the energy
of the atoms there,
and therefore, we
find that the energy
of the atoms in steady
state is given by, actually,
the ratio of heating
versus cooling.
It's a simple expression.
The energy or the limiting
temperature for molasses
is the ratio of
heating versus cooling.
Heating is described by momentum
diffusion coefficient and alpha
is described by
the damping force.
I want you, actually, to
keep this expression in mind.
A limit in temperature
in laser cooling
is always-- actually, in other
processes in laser cooling--
is the ratio of
heating over cooling.
And momentum diffusion
coefficient due to heating,
over a friction
force due to cooling.
Because we will later find
polarization gradient cooling,
cooling in blue
molasses, we will
find other cooling
schemes, where
we will calculate-- with
the appropriate model--
the heating and the cooling.
And I don't have to
repeat this part.
The moment I calculate
the heating, the momentum
diffusion, and I
calculate the friction,
I know what the limiting
temperatures is.
Again, when I said, the
energy is kt over 2, you know,
of course, kinetic energy is
kt over 2 times the number
of degrees of freedom.
I assumed 1D, here.
So in everything I've
said on this page,
there are numerical
factors which
may change whether you assume
one or two or three dimension.
OK.
I think that's the last
thing I want to tell you.
And then on Wednesday
we do Zeeman's slowing
and Magneto-optical trapping.
We had an expression for alpha.
Remember we had this Lorentz
profile, for the other Lorentz
profile, and alpha
was just the slope.
I mean, everything is known.
I just didn't bother
to calculate it.
But it just involves
derivative of Lorentzian.
And now we can ask, what
is the lowest temperature
we can reach?
Well, you can now analyze
your expression for alpha
for a two-level system solved
by the Optical Bloch Equation.
And you find that you will have
the most favorable conditions
for low temperature-- you
get the minimum possible
temperature-- in the
limit of low laser power.
And your detuning--
your optimum detuning--
is half a line width away.
And then you'll find
this famous result,
that if you cool
a two-level atom,
the limiting
temperature is simply
given by the spontaneous
emission rate,
or the line width of
your transition, gamma.
And this is the famous
result for the Doppler limit.
For sodium atoms,
it's 250 micro-Kelvin,
for rubidium and cesium,
because of the heavier mass,
it's lower, is 10's
of micro-Kelvin, 50
or 100 micro-Kelvin.
So this is a famous limit.
And the physics of
it is the following,
the narrower the line width is.
Then you can say the better
you can cool particle down
to zero temperature--
and I think,
Jenny, your idea of
the Raman process
comes now in very handy--
I can have an atom,
and I can have a Raman process
where I scatter photons
and go to higher energy
or I scatter photons
and got to lower energy.
And the difference
between the two processes
is actually, the one
that whether I cool
or whether I heat comes
from the Doppler effect.
So the more I can discriminate
between through the Doppler
effect, the better I can cool.
But the Doppler effect--
the Doppler shift,
kv-- how well I can
resolve it, depends
on the width of the
atomic transition.
The narrower the
atomic transition,
the more the Doppler effect
can steer the laser cooling--
the Raman process--
towards lower velocity,
not towards higher velocity.
So that's the natural result
that the-- or an expected
result-- that the natural
line width appears here.
OK.
I've talked a few extra minutes.
Is there any question?
Then I see you on Wednesday.